قلوب ومورز فيديو
[موسيقى]
بدات العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا
اوكرانيا السبب الوحيد في ذلك حسب الرئيس
بوتين فالمساله اكبر من سياسه عدوانيه
لدوله جاره لطالما جمعتها بروسيا يوما
دوله الاتحاد السوفيتي انه حلف الناتو
المعضله الاهم بالنسبه لموسكو وتمدده
المستمر ببنيته العسكريه نحو الشرق نحو
حدودها
حاولت روسيا عشيه التصعيد باشهر احتواء
الوضع فقدمت مقترحات للغرب هو على راسه
الولايات المتحده تطالب فيها بالحصول على
ضمانات امنيه ابرزها عدم استخدام اراضي
دول ثالثه للتحضير او تنفيذ هجوم عسكري
منع تمدد النيتو شرقا او استخدام اراضي
الدول الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق غير
الاعضاء في الناتو لنشر قواعد عسكريه على
اراضيها في اشاره الى اوكرانيا
مقترحات لم تلقى لا ترحيبا غربيا ولا رغبه
في الاستماع للهواجس الروسيه الامر الذي
اعتبرته روسيا النقطه الاخيره او كما قال
بوتين اختراقا للخطوط الحمر الروسيه
حراك عسكري غير مسبوق على طول الحدود
الروسيه الاوكرانيه كان اشاره الى ان شيئا
ما سيحدث هذا الشيء بقيت روسيا تنفيه وتس
خر منه حتى اخر لحظه رغم كل المعطيات
والاشارات والتاكيدات الغربيه على تدخل
روسي عسكري وشيكا في اوكرانيا
تواصلت الاحداث كالصاعقه على مر ثلاثه
ايام متتاليه
اعتبروا انه من الضروري اتخاذ قرار ازف
وقته منذ فتره طويله وهو الاعتراف فورا
باستقلال جمهوريتي لوغانسك
اعترفت روسيا اذا باستقلال جمهوريتين
لوغانس كوادانيتك عن اوكرانيا والاهم من
ذلك وقعت معهما معاهده الصداقه والتعاون
والمساعده وشرع نت روسيا بموجبها كل
خطواتها المستقبليه داخل اوكرانيا ومات لا
ذلك سوى طلب رسمي من قبل رئيسي
الجمهوريتين اللتين بتتا مستقلتين بالنسبه
لروسيا
ليستفيق العالم في الرابع من فبراير على
وقع احداث ستصبح لاحقا الاكثر دمويه في
تاريخ اوروبا الحديث
عام كامل مر على انطلاق العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا عام قد لا تكون روسيا
حققت خلاله الاهداف التي وضعتها في
اوكرانيا لكن ما لا شك فيه هو تمسك موسكو
المبدئي بتحقيق هذه الاهداف رغم العقوبات
والتسليح والدعم المستمر لاوكرانيا
والتاكيد على حتميه النصر الروسي ليس على
اوكرانيا وحسب بل وعلما تسميه بالغرب
الجماعي موسكو